una sorpresa completa y probablemente
nunca conoceremos Ni tendremos certeza
de todas las razones Boris Johnson en
esta carta ha dicho que tiene la certeza
de que tendría más de 100 apoyos de 100
diputados conservadores que respaldarían
su candidatura Pero ha concluido después
de meditarlo mucho que no sería lo
correcto para hacer ha dicho entre otras
que ha meditado sobre este posibilidad y
que sabe que para que un gobierno sea
exitoso requiere el apoyo de un partido
Unido Y eso no lo tiene en este momento
pero dejó la puerta para abierta para el
futuro dijo que tiene muchísimo que
ofrecer y habló de las elecciones de
2024 digo que se ha reunido en las
últimas horas desde que terminó sus
vacaciones abrutamente en la República
Dominicana con los otros dos candidatos
con Richie sunaki con Penny Morgan pero
no fue posible llegar a acuerdos Lo
cierto es que sí Por eso son si hubiera
presentado hubiera tenido altísimas
probabilidades de ser elegido Primer
Ministro pero lo cierto es que un
segundo gobierno hubiera sido muchísimo
más polémico que el primero porque
Johnson Aún está siendo investigado por
el parlamento para establecer si mintió
o no deliberadamente sobre el partygate
si fuera encontrado culpable Entonces
sería forzado nuevamente a renunciar la
sola posibilidad de que Johnson fuera
candidato dividió no solamente al país
sino que aún más a su propio partido el
partido conservador Luisa hace las cosas
quedan en la baraja Regina y la líder de
los conservadores en la cámara de los
comunes Penny Morgan ellos son los dos
últimos candidatos en esta baraja cuando
podríamos conocer Entonces el nombre del
nuevo líder del partido conservador
la fecha límite es el Viernes 28 de
octubre pero con Boris Johnson
quitándose del camino dejando este
despejado para Richie sunat existe la
alta probabilidad de que Richie sea
Coronado este lunes como nuevo Primer
Ministro británico según las
estimaciones tiene más de 150 apoyos de
diputados conservadores y eso le
garantizarían estar en la final y
convertirse en el nuevo Primer Ministro
Pero por supuesto en política no hay
nada escrito este lunes se realizarán
las votaciones Y entonces habrá que
esperar como terminan pero las
predicciones es que
richiesunak será Coronado como nuevo
Primer Ministro y de ser así sería el
primer primer británico de origen indio
y sin duda una de las personas más ricas
que ha sido ocupante de Downey Street